all right so yes I want to talk about
some joint work with Rob Morris and it's
a basic question that Rob Morris and I
were interested in looking at was
questions at the following type so what
you want to know is how many sets are
there how many sets a and you can ask
this question in various different
contexts so you might ask in the
interval 1 up to n is one example were
interested in or other settings or in
modular NZ or backspace' over finite
field etc so choose your favorite
setting how many sets a are there with a
certain specified size the size of a is
K and who some said also has a specified
size and the size of the subset a plus a
so there's a huge number of questions
here depending on what the group is and
what the relative sizes of K and M are
but this is the basic type of question
where you're interested in looking at
okay so well maybe I'll tell you one of
our results about this before I launch
into some so-called applications now
let's think of just just about this
setting here so let's think about
subsets of the first n integers
the what about sets a contained inside
one up to n so what's the possible range
of values of M so fairly trivially M has
always got to be between two K minus one
that's the smallest it can be and K
choose two may be plus K 1/2 K k plus
one so somehow as anyone who's done some
additive combinatorics would be familiar
with the lower end of this spectrum here
is where a is extremely structured
equality only occurs this is a - yes
sorry the lower end of the spectrum here
is where a is very structured it's an
arithmetic progression and the upper end
is where a is some highly unstructured
sort of random like set though most of
the new work that Rob Morris and I did
on this question had to do with this end
of the of the spectrum here so let me
fix let's fix a value of K Big K and and
ask how many a contained in one up to n
have size K little K and the size of
their sunset is less than big K times
little K
yeah it's annoying isn't it but some I
can I think my I think you can tell you
can tell between them somehow
yeah so let's think of K as being I
don't fix this a turn or something it
used to be the case that this this is
the doubling constant it is pretty much
always called big K that's why we had to
use big K here I guess I could have
chosen something other than little K but
it used to be a decade or so ago this
used to be called C but now C is just an
art I mean I think C has always just
been an arbitrary constant which can
vary so Spencer that's good idea
blackboard bold caper but then what
field am i working over anyway hopefully
there isn't too much genuine danger of
confusion here so I've got a fixed value
of the doubling constants I want to know
how many subsets of one up to n there
are which double by at most that amount
so what about some lower bounds for this
so can i construct at least a fairly big
collection of sets with this with this
property well there are two different
ways that I want to show you of
constructing sets with doubling
constants at most K they're construction
one one thing you could do is just take
an arithmetic progression of length that
P contained in 1 up to M be any
arithmetic progression
of length it K times little K over 2 and
then however you choose a inside there
they let a contained in P be arbitrary
that sort of size if okay
then because a plus a is contained in P
plus P I certainly have a plus a is at
most the size of P plus P which is
basically big K times little K so any
set like that will be will have this
property that it has size K and it's
doubling is at most big K so this gives
well basically big K times little K over
to choose K sets
so that's one type of construction
a second type of construction is I could
take a to be just an arithmetic
progression P yeah so I'll let me
elaborate upon that in just a moment
there are n scruff Li n squared
different ways of choosing peace so let
a be some arithmetic progression
together with Union just a few extra
elements so X 1 up to X sub K minus 2 or
something like that big K minus 2 where
the xir arbitrary
so you can just you can convince
yourself that if you add this set to
itself what you basically get is P
doubled in length together with K minus
2 translates of P and then a few extra
points but roughly speaking the doubling
of this set is also at most big K
slightly roughly a plus a has size at
most big K so how many ways are there of
choosing a set like this well this is
more related to what avi said I can
choose the progression P in about N
squared different ways choose the base
point in the common difference and then
I can also choose those points in about
n different ways and each of them in
about n different ways so this gives
again roughly because I need to I might
have accidentally chosen a set that sort
of pushes outside of the interval 1 up
to N or something but roughly n to the
big K choices of a
okay so well the main theorem of Rob
Morris and I on this problem of counting
some sets is that roughly speaking these
two examples give you all of the in some
sense account for essentially all of the
sets a with this property there may be
something additionally that I'll point
out is that somehow one of these wins so
this construction wins if little K is
bigger than log n because you get
exponential in K things here and this
construction wins in the regime that K
is little o of log in there the theorem
a theorem of Rob Morris and myself is
that the number that's a in one up to n
with its size little K and doubling
constant it K that most big K is roughly
the product of these two functions
so it's roughly big k little k over to
choose K times n to the big K and I'm
going to I won't say precisely what I
mean by roughly so it's um
as long as you're not in the critical
range where these two constructions
somewhat overlap this is asymptotically
correct if you take the log but so
somehow the idea is that this is a
pretty decent estimation of the of the
number of assets say with this property
and there is a precise statement in our
paper that you could look up if you feel
so inclined multi-is multiplied yeah I
mean the thing is that so I guess the
roughly means an asymptotic of the log
and outside of this so for most values
of K less K is comparable to log in one
of these two terms massively dominates
the other so it doesn't yeah but
actually the way the proof goes it's
more natural to write x so that's the
basic idea the Y will well I mean I
guess we're really interested in this
for its own sake but I want to tell you
some applications of this
so the first application has to do with
the topic that I started studying when I
was doing my PhD and it's to do with
random Kelly graphs so I got interested
in this because I mean probably most
people here know about Ramsey's theorem
and the fact that you can get a a two
coloring of of a graph on n vertices
with no large clique or no large red or
blue click by taking a random coloring
and everybody thinks that such things as
the quadratic residue graph where you
take vertex set Z mod p and join X to Y
if X plus y is a quadratic residue
should be a good ramsey graph I'll say
some more about that particular example
a bit later it seems to be completely
hopeless to prove any statement like
that in fact we can't really show that
it has no cleat site larger than about
square root of P but what I wondered was
whether at least that type of
construction should be able to give you
a good ramsey graph so the question is
so can Cayley graphs and be good ramsey
graphs
so more specifically let's consider
constructions of the following type so
for a in Zeb modular NZ form a graph G
of a on vertex set said modern said by
joining X to Y if and only if X plus y
lies in a now this is not quite the
usual definition of calligraphic I
suppose I should really call this a
Cayley sub graph but the purposes of
everything I'm going to say today it
would also work for Cayley grass but in
that case to make the graph well-defined
you have to assume that a is symmetric
and it just becomes a bit of
notationally annoying so this is a
perfectly valid construction of a graph
from a set so eg
a common construction and prime a is the
quadratic residues modulo n
so the question is can you choose a so
that GA has no large clique or
independent set
and perhaps also and I'm going to talk
about this question four random sets a
this should perhaps also give you some
intuition about what you would expect
for the for the quadratic residue graph
and there's actually been various things
written in the literature about what one
might expect for the quadratic residue
graph and some of those things I think
are wrong so I think it basically does
behave like a random graph I'll try and
justify that in a bit
so the question the theorem that I
proved in my thesis about this was that
if you pick a randomly says select
suppose n is prime and select a Zed mod
NZ at random then almost surely as n
tends to infinity the clique number of
this Cayley graph click number of GA is
at least bounded by a constant times the
log of n and Rob Morris and I have
updated this Bob Morris and myself 2013
can I get that we can get the tight
asymptotic for this so it's actually 2
plus epsilon for any epsilon greater
than 0 this is basically this is the
most 2 plus epsilon times log 2 and so
same as for a genuinely random graph
so no it is toad yeah at some so equals
plus little a1 yeah in fact the lower
bound is pretty easy actually um one
thing I should remark about this is
although I won't say much more about
this point but this question is quite
delicate as regards which group you
choose so something I showed 10 years
ago is that if you do the same
construction but you choose a random
subset not of Zed mod n ZD for Emma
Prime but for effect space over finite
fields then this is not correct
so in fact in that setting so if Zedd
mod NZ is replaced by f2 to the N where
2 to the N is big n let's say then
almost surely the clique number is
bigger than log n times an extra log not
and actually that's also shot I mean up
to the constant it behaves like log n
times log log n so it's sort of a bit
sensitive to the group you choose and
somehow and actually there's a lot
that's still mysterious about this I've
no real clue what happens for example in
non abelian groups
let me just yeah now I'm going to say in
a moment what the link between this type
of question and the Counting sunsets
type of question is but before I do that
let me just say a few words about the
the quadratic residue graph so there's a
slightly curious feature of the
quadratic residue graph which is that
actually it's not quite as good as
choosing a random set a so there's a
result of Graham and ring rows which
tells you that if a is the quadratic
residues
what n then the click number of that
graph the quadratic residue graph is
bigger than log n times log log log n
for infinitely many N and you can you
can state and prove a more precise
version of this theorem of Rob Morrison
myself to show that if you took if you
take a random sequence of graphs one for
each prime then almost surely all of the
Clete numbers will be bounded by a
constant times log n so somehow these
quadratic residue graphs are behaving
not quite like random graphs
well I K yeah let me tell you one or two
things let me let me explain somehow the
reason that quadratic residue graphs
behaves slightly anomalously in this
respect so the reason is reason is that
it's possible for the numbers 1 2 3 4 up
to sort of log n log log log n to all be
quadratic residues
modulo n and if they aren't real
quadratic residues then you get a clique
of size 1/2 this just by taking the the
interval of the numbers up to 1/2 log n
times log log log n so why is that
possible well basically the intuition is
that as n varies over Prime's the
quadratic residue symbols at primes so 2
Legendre and 3 Legendre N and so on up
to Q Legendre n they behave like
independent random variables somehow as
n ranges over Prime's so it's very
difficult to prove statements like that
this is basically somehow what the
generalized Riemann hypothesis is
telling you or one one application of
that but if you assume that these do
behave like independent coin tosses you
should expect that they come up heads
all of them come up heads even if Q is
about as big as where you can afford to
take log n Prime's and still expect that
sometimes they will all come up heads so
this is the log nth prime and actually
the log n prime is about log n times log
log n which is even better than what
gram and ring rows get but they didn't
have the generalized Riemann hypothesis
available to them so if all those coins
come up heads then because of the
multiplicative 'ti of the Legendre
symbol in fact all of the numbers less
than Q not just the primes are quadratic
residues so that's what goes on however
for a typical value of n these won't all
come up heads probably half of them will
come up heads and then you don't get
anything like this behavior and although
I haven't tried to write anything like
this down what I suspect is that the
correct conjectures about the quadratic
residue graph come from imagining that
these are independent coin tosses and
then somehow the rest of the graph
behaves like a random
Graff in other words I would conjecture
that for almost all in the klique number
of the quadratic residue graph is
basically twice log in twice log to the
base 2 of n so that contradicts this and
I don't know if they're really
conjectures but there's some numerical
evidence out there apparently that the
clean numbers of these quadratic residue
graphs are less than a random graph I've
seen that written down I would - that
okay so yes No so if you see if you
choose a sequence one of sets one for
each prime then almost surely the clique
number will be banded by 2 plus little o
1 log to the base 2 event for all M yeah
there's a Sun Burrell can tele argument
you can do now let me just explain
briefly what this problem has got to do
with counting Sun sets it's quite easy
to explain so what is the expected
number so suppose that a is random they
contained in said mod n zeroes picked at
random what is the expected number of
cake leaks in the Kayla graph
any 12ga well let's sum over all sets of
size a is a terrible that is a terrible
piece of notation sets of size X so X is
going to be the set of vertices that's
supposed to be being a a cake link
what's the probability that the click
that that set of vertices which is a set
of K elements in said modern said what's
the probability that that spans a click
in the Kelly graph well it's just
precisely 2 to the power of minus X plus
X it's actually not quite that you have
to say what's good the restricted subset
which means that you're not interested
in adding X to X itself little extra
little X itself there you can split this
up according to the size of X plus X
size of X plus X equals M and then it's
just the number of says X in Z mod n Zed
sighs okay
whose subset has size M times 2 to the
minus M so you sum this over K and M so
in other words if you have good bounds
for the number of sets with a certain
subset you get good bands for the number
the expected number of cake leaks in the
random Kayla graph sorry just yeah just
mmm
but and so you want to show
well basically you throw into this the
best bounds you have for this quantity
obviously and you hope that you can show
that this is little o of one with caping
as small as possible so with K being two
plus epsilon times log to the base 2 of
big n so that's the aim so actually the
way that the various bounds for this
quantity feed back into calculating the
expected number of K clicks is quite
complicated and actually so the the
result that Rob Morris and I proved is
only about when M is small in comparison
to K it turns out one also needs to
consider various other ranges of M in
terms of K but the the bounds for that
were already in my my earlier paper on
on this subject so it all feeds into
this
if you want to say something about how
one goes about counting these sunsets
but just before I do that I want to
mention one other application and one
reason I want to mention this is that
I'm not actually convinced that this is
not trivial maybe it is trivial somebody
could come up to me afterwards and say
but can't you just do this so here's a
second application of counting some sets
results choose a set of natural numbers
at random let a be in the natural
numbers be chosen at random so what I
mean by that it's just pick each element
to lie in a with probability 1/2
independently then the probability that
a plus a mrs. K integers is equal to 2
to the minus K over 2 times 1 plus
little o of 1 so the subset of the set a
will be an infinite set of density or
1/2 it will almost surely cover all
sufficiently large integers when you the
sum of it with itself will almost surely
cover it sufficiently large integers the
probability that it misses out K of them
is exactly this and it's easy to see
that that Sharpe up to the little air
one because if a misses a is disjoint
from one up to K over 2 which does
happen with probability 2 to the minus K
over 2 then a plus a this is some one
uptick
so we I mean we have to throw all of our
bounds at this to get this thing but I
um I have a suspicion that this is
perhaps not as hard as all that who note
the strange thing then the remaining
time I want to say a few things about
how you count sets with small silent
now how do we count that's a contained
in one up to n with a fixed size little
K and with doubling constant at most bit
K then the basic idea is that we can't
them by isomorphism class so we can't
them by isomorphism class and the notion
of isomorphism I'm talking about here is
what's called Fryman isomorphism there
are two sets of Fryman isomorphic if
they have the same additive structure so
a frame and isomorphism PI from a set a
to a set B is a Fryman isomorphism if
well PI of a 1 if it preserves additive
relations of length 2 so PI of a 1 plus
PI over 2 is equal to PI of a three plus
PI by 4 if and only if a 1 plus a 2
equals a 3 plus a 4 so
the idea is that somehow many of the
sets a with small doubling will be
isomorphic to one another so for example
all arithmetic progressions are
isomorphic so we split the problem into
two beds connecting the number of
isomorphism classes so we count the
number of isomorphism classes but when
you can't hit the number of isomorphism
classes you need to count the number of
embeddings from some chosen set in that
isomorphism class back into 1 up to n
and then or a given set be the number of
isomorphisms I from B into 1 up to n so
that's the basic strategy for counting
and the two bits have quite different
flavors so there's a very nice result by
Russia which is used in his proof of
Freeman's theorem and maybe I should
have said so somehow for anyone who's
looked at some additive combinatorics
put the first strategy that presents
itself when you ask how many sets the
rile with doubling at most K is why not
try and apply froman's theorem so
frien's theorem tells you that a is
contained in a grid of small dimension
unfortunately the containment parameters
are necessarily somewhat bad and so if
you apply Prime it's theorem it will
tell you that a is contained in a grid
but most of the sets contained in that
same grid and if the same size as a will
have doubling two to the power K so it's
completely useless unfortunately but in
the course of the proof of froman's
theorem rusev proved what's called the
rooters model lemma which is that every
set every a contained in one up to n
with size little K and doubling constant
at most big K is Fryman isomorphic
to a subset of Zedd modulo Q Zed where Q
is a prime that's really similar size to
K U is a prime and Q has size at most
just a constant times little K so
constant time to live okay so you can
think of it like this you've got some
you're interested in sets a inside one
up to n which have small doubling so I
don't know and they look like some grid
perhaps but by applying one of these
frame and isomorphisms you can make them
a dense subset of cyclic they to solve
the first problem
how many Fryman isomorphism classes have
sets with doubling at most some constant
there are it suffices to solve it inside
a cyclic group for large sets inside a
cyclic group
so how do we solve that problem here's
my cyclic crude Zed modular Q Zed well
what we do is prove a type of regularity
lemma that's somewhat related to what's
called by some people the arithmetic
regularity lemma and the statement is
potentially useful elsewhere it states
that if you take a dense subset of Z
naught Q where Q is a prime then after
dilating the set the set looks like this
so you can divide up said mod Q into
roughly equal bits so I've divided it
into Q primed bits you primed pieces
where Q prime is another prime
and on or basically on on those pieces
on most of those pieces your set looks
highly pseudo-random so let's let's give
us an answer I suppose s is a settings
ever more cute it looks like this it's
sort of highly in some of these chunks
then some of the chunks there will be
none of us and then in some other chunks
the said S will be highly pseudo-random
looking yeah the pieces are intervals I
won't get the precise statement it's so
what we actually get is the length of
the intervals is at least tends to
infinity with Q and the the regularity
segment is that most pairs of intervals
have us what we call serve a joint
regularity property when I say highly
pseudo-random what I mean is that when
you add the contents of this interval so
the contents of this interval you get
essentially all of the contents of the
summed intervals so it means that you
have a situation like this so you have a
some sort of pseudo random set here and
another pseudo-random set here and when
you add them together you get pretty
much the entire interval of twice the
length
as I said I haven't stated this
regularity lemma precisely but one thing
that's perhaps interesting about it is
that it doesn't require tower type
bounds so it's it requires merely double
exponential bounds but it's proven in a
similar way to the usual regularity
limits by a sort of energy
incrementation argument mmm I don't know
of any English it's directly analogous
to those fries kind of gives you sort of
one and maybe it is actually quite
certain on some level maybe it is
similar to that
okay so suppose you have such a lemmas
and this is somehow a picture of what
just a typical dense subset of zed mod Q
looks like how do we use this to count
sets well if the doubling of s is a is
at most K so I know that some I'm
assuming that the size of s is K and
it's doubling is that most big K but I
know what happens when I add this set s
to itself basically whenever I have an
interval that contains some bit of s
when I add the bit of s in that interval
to the bit of s in another interval I
get everything in the sum of those two
intervals so let's let I don't know T be
the set of intervals on which s has mass
and then s plus s is pretty much all off
T plus T but T plus T is at least twice
the length of T by the Koshi Davenport
theorem but T plus T is at least twice
the length of T by Koshu Davenport
so the Koshu Davenport theorems tells
you that when you add two sets of
residues modulo Prime the size of their
Sun sets at least basically the size of
the two sets and here okay I've not got
sets of residues I've got intervals but
they're indexed by somehow is that mod Q
Prime said so when I happen together I
get the set of intervals again is at
least twice the length that's what of
what I had before
and so therefore this length of T has
got to be at most big K times little K
over 2
they're the set s which is supposed to
have doubling at most Big K has been
selected from a union of intervals of
length at most big K little K over 2 and
these I mean there aren't many unions of
intervals they're extremely sort of
blocky type sets so let's just suppose
with some small number of those and then
for each of them I'm selecting K
elements from a set of this size so this
is where I get a bound so gives
basically Big K little K over 2 choose K
choices for s so that's roughly how we
managed to count the number of from and
isomorphism classes of sets of small
doubling just to recap there's something
called bridges model lemma that says you
can always find a Fryman isomorphic copy
of your set in a cyclic group once
you're in the cyclic group every set has
this kind of block like structure by a
regularity lemma and then you can
control the number of blocks on which
you have to worry about there being any
portion of your set by the Koshi
davenport theorem so that's a very rough
sketch there's a whole nother part of
the argument which is once i've got from
an isomorphic copy of a i have to figure
out how many embeddings there are back
into one up to em i shan't say anything
about that other than that it's the
number of such isomorphisms is very
closely linked to what's called the
Fryman dimension of the set and there's
some geometric arguments of Fryman that
let you bound that in fact the Fryman
dimension of a set of doubling K is
actually bounded by K so okay I think
I'm out of time
yeah so I did not think about that I
mean that has to do with looking at
these things in quite sparse settings
right so you're you're not going to be
choosing a random settee you choose run
today with probability P where P is
pretty small actually Naga along has a
very general question which is to show
that if you choose so if you're just in
a group G of size n and if you choose a
random set of size T then he conjectures
that the clique number should be the
independence number should be basically
n over T times a log factor and I
thought briefly about this but it it's
quite a lot more difficult than these
things it requires it's going to require
some more subtle estimates for these and
but counting the number of sets with a
specified sunset but for quite a lot
bigger values of K and you're going to
need some quite precise things that
seemed it seemed to me so that seems
quite difficult
yeah yeah but this random subsets of
integers if you pick them with some
other probably one third or something
like that yeah we left that open in our
paper I mean yes you'd get an answer for
that so if you if you choose if you
choose a set of natural numbers at
random by picking each element aligned
set with probability of third then you
could calculate the probability that it
misses out K elements asymptotically or
something is always missing the first I
think so for fixed values of P we didn't
really bother to look at it looked the
question would become quite a lot more
subtle if you started pushing P to be I
guess there's some thresholds known for
when a random set of integers is even a
basis so if you choose P to be like 1
over N to the 1 but so you include n to
be a new set with probability like 1
over N to the 1/2 or something a little
bit modern man then almost surely it's a
basis I think it would be pretty
difficult to figure out the probability
that it emits K elements in that regime
but for constant P there would be no
problem
I would guess that exactly the same
techniques work because every subset of
our to the D in fact is front and
isomorphic to a subset of zet so you
basically can't hit the same thing here
but you'd have to be a little bit more
careful about I'm not even yes it
probably should be K over four or
something if you're in two dimensions
our methods would give an answer so it's
um I suspect the correct probabilistic
model of the quadratic residues is that
it behaves like a random plus a minus
one multiplicative function on somehow
yes I mean I guess the point is the
quadratic residue symbol is
multiplicative so somehow the way to
model it would be its values on the
first few primes that independently plus
or minus one and then after that it just
behaves like a completely random plus or
minus one function so it sort of got a
little bit of multiplicative 'ti at the
start I would guess but I haven't worked
out that if you take that model for it
you conclude that somehow a random
function in that class has the graph has
cleat number twice log two
it's sort of analyzing random
multiplicative function is not that easy
but it is sort of doable